when I first saw Blade Runner I was done
with the Scots vision struck so many
courts I could immediately recognize its
impact on the entire cinematic world now
I've been given the amazing opportunity
to continue the story and direct Blade
Runner 2049 which picks up 30 years
after the first film so with that in
mind I decided to ask a couple of
artists that I respect to create three
short stories that dramatize some key
events that occurred after 2019 when the
first Blade Runner takes place but
before 2049 when my new Blade Runner
story begins my friend Luke Scott has
directed this short film you're about to
see I hope you enjoyed this special
glimpse into the world of Blade Runner
2036 Oh memory bearings from the time
they're all damaged in the blackout but
there are sometimes fragments
[Applause]
no conclusion session
11:17 p.m. testimony of me and of
wallace to the magistrate sectors dl 1
or 9 through 26 and so forth
ended md thank you for your patience I
did not intend to keep you waiting the
particular zuv my affliction make a
little difficult
mr. Wallace we've granted you this
meeting and deference to your
contributions they are centuries we
recognize that for the public good for
their health
you remember hunger so you indulge the
recluse whose patents keep that hunger
at bay
I believe in life
in fact I have run more life from our
earth than ever before but it is dying
you are dying which brings us to our
present concern core vision we have made
clear our position the prohibition of
replicant technology is not subject to
debate no is its repeal and yet we are
debating not we all that was lost in the
blackout this cut of history died the
more humanity has only survived this
long by crushing the earth to suit its
needs the Stars our only hope are hidden
behind the lives you will not allow me
to create offworld colonies are thriving
insufficient to the needs of ultimate
survival your laws have changed the
hands of progress laws keep blood off
the streets
Nexus phase is unreliable safeguards put
in place by Tyrell with negligent to
many have died we will not add to that
number
my replicants will live as long or as
short as a customer will pay my
replicants will never repel they will
never run they simply obey
step forward find your weapon do this
now what is this this is an angel and I
made him look up to the left reveal
you're committing a crime Wallace that's
enough
lift the glass god no no no no no this
is wrong
does it hurt yes you must make a choice
your life or mine do you understand yes
do this now this is wrong
human action resounds in the heavens the
bell echoes above what we decide here
today will polish or crack the firmament
which Allah P
you